Medical Aid in dying it's been a
contentious issue for years we do thank
you for joining us at 11 I'm Brian
Loftus and I'm Denise Valdez it's just
one step away right now from potentially
becoming law here in Nevada now it
allows a physician to prescribe pills to
a terminally ill patient and help them
end their life peacefully Sasha loft is
joining us tonight with more on what
this means for our state
Brian if this bill becomes law Nevada
will join 10 other states in Washington
D.C which have legalized medical Aid in
dying we heard both sides of the issue
tonight as those behind it wait for the
Governor's final decision Linda Brooks
Gracie has terminal cancer the medical
community has said there's nothing else
they can do for me as she nears the end
of her life she says she wants the power
to choose so she's supporting the Nevada
Medical Aid and dying Bill the measure
also known as Senate Bill 239 made its
way through the legislature this week
and will now go to Governor Lombardo's
desk this bill will set a policy that
nevadans have been asking for for a very
long time Sarah Manns of compassion
choices Network says it's something many
have been asking for While others call
it the wrong choice this bill puts
health care workers in a position of
decision making that is not in our
training nor ethics I do remain
concerned about abuses that will and can
occur in order to get an end-of-life
pill a patient must be 18 mentally
competent and diagnosed as terminal by
two different doctors that person would
also need to make two verbal requests
for the medication and submit a written
request signed by a witness having
access to it here at home in Nevada is
going to make such a difference man says
this and other protections make it the
best chance for anyone suffering this is
a last option but it's the best option
while Linda hopes others will understand
why this means so much to her it's about
Choice SB 239 also ensures the death
would not be described as a suicide but
instead listed as the terminal illness
that patient had it also provides legal
protection for any medical professionals
involved at this time Governor Lombardo
has not indicated whether or not he
plans to sign this Denise well there
have been fact several attempts in past
legislative sessions to pass similar
Medical Aid and dying bills but SB 239
is actually the first that would allow a
patient to end their own life with a
prescription instead of having a doctor
administer the medication